إن خيار دلتا المتغير الذي يضع
خطط العودة إلى المكتب قيد الانتظار ، يعمل متغير دلتا الجدارة
على تحويل المحادثة
بعيدًا عن أنه يجب علينا العودة إلى العمل ، يا
إلهي ، علينا أن نفكر بشكل
نقدي حول معنى العمل الآن
تقول المستشارة أمبر كابريل أن العديد
من عملائها  ينتظرون ويرون الوضع بينما
ينضم عمالقة التكنولوجيا إلى القائمة المتزايدة من
الشركات التي تدفع خططها لأشهر
في المستقبل جوجل وأوبر نقل
تاريخ عودتهما إلى أكتوبر فيسبوك
أمازون وأبل يؤجلان العودة إلى
مكاتب الشركة حتى يناير على الأقل
يدفعان العودة حتى  بعد
فبراير ، يقول كابريلو إن المديرين
يعتمدون على الموظفين للتحلي بالصبر
والمرونة ، لكن هذه ليست مجرد
محادثة عنك تعرف ما الذي
يحدث مع متغير دلتا ، إنها أيضًا
محادثة حول الأشخاص الذين يعدلون
حياتهم.
حريصًا على استعادة
الشعور بالإحباط حقًا ومن ثم يكون لديك
الأشخاص الرائعون لأنني لم أكن
مستعدًا للعودة إلى  في المكتب ، فإن
التأخير يمنح المديرين مزيدًا من الوقت
للتشجيع أو في بعض الحالات فرض
لقاحات ، ومع وجود بعض الصناعات التي تواجه
نقصًا في العمالة ، يقول أصحاب العمل إنهم لا
يريدون خسارة أي شخص بسبب التفويضات أو
إجبارهم على العودة إلى مكان العمل في وقت مبكر جدًا
مع حوالي 18 شهرًا من
المكتب ، بعض العمال ليسوا مستعدين بعد
للتخلي عن المرونة والراحة
والأمان للعمل من المنزل. أنا
أنتج المزيد من العمل. 2 يمكن أن أكون مسؤولاً
فعليًا ، لست بحاجة فعليًا إلى أن أكون
جسديًا في المكتب لمشاهدة المستهلك
i '  م مندي جيثر